americans are feeling the pain at the
pumps earlier this year the cost of
filling up the car with petrol hit an
all-time high in the u.s
the war in ukraine has hit russian oil
imports a u.s house subcommittee called
a meeting to discuss what can be done to
help
but the hearing quickly dissolved into
political bickering democrats claiming
oil companies are padding profits at the
consumer's expense
if the price of gas is driven by the
global market
why is the price of oil coming down but
the price at the pump
is still near record highs
if it's an issue of supply and demand
wouldn't that be reflected in the global
price of oil as well
something just doesn't add up
but for the republicans it was clear who
was to blame since president biden took
office the prices of crude oil and many
other energy commodities have risen to
the highest level in more than a decade
as a direct result of president biden's
anti-american energy agenda
five big energy companies were
represented all denied they were using
the ukraine war to jack up profits
mr woods
is your company taking advantage of the
crisis you came to keep prices
artificially high in order to increase
your own profits
absolutely not
mr wirth no we are not
mr lawler
absolutely not
ms watkins
no we are not the hearing was aimed at
helping u.s consumers but the cost of
fuel will be a big political issue come
the mid-term elections in november
so the hearing became about scoring
political points
rather than cutting costs for ordinary
american families
alan fisher al jazeera on capitol hill